Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work doesn't have a ton of viewable footage,
but I think it is an absolutely amazing piece
of craftsmanship, so in the first half of
this video, we'll roll some footage from earlier
episodes, and in the second half, you'll see
the new stuff.
In this series, we often talk about reinforcement
learning, which is a learning technique where
an agent chooses an optimal series of actions
in an environment to maximize a score.
Playing computer games is a good example of
a clearly defined score that is to be maximized.
As long as we can say that the higher the
score, the better the learning, the concept
will work for helicopter control, choosing
the best spot for wifi connectivity or a large
variety of different tasks.
However, what about environments where multiple
agents or players are present?
Not all games are single player focused, and
not all helicopters have to fly alone.
So what about that?
To deal with cases like this, scientists at
OpenAI and the University of Oxford came up
with a work by the name "Learning with Opponent-Learning
Awareness", LOLA in short, or lola.
I have to say that the naming game at OpenAI
has been quite strong lately.
This is about multiplayer reinforcement learning,
if you will.
This new agent does not only care about maximizing
its own score but also inserts a new term
into the equation which is about anticipating
the actions of other players in the environment.
It is not only possible to do this, but they
also show that it can be done in an effective
way, and, the best part is that it also gives
rise to classical strategies that game theory
practitioners will immediately recognize.
For instance, it can learn tit for tat, which
is a strategy that mirrors the other player's
actions.
This means that if the other player is cooperative,
it will remain cooperative, but if it gets
screwed over, it will also try to screw others
over.
You'll see in a moment why this is a big deal.
The prisoner's dilemma is a game where two
criminals are caught and are independently
interrogated, and have to choose whether they
snitch on the other one or not.
If any one snitches out, there will be hell
to pay for the other one.
If they both defect, they both serve a fair
amount time in prison.
The score to be minimized is therefore this
time spent in prison.
The optimal solution of this game is when
both criminals remain silent, and this strategy
is something that we call the Nash equilibrium.
In other words, this is the best set of actions
if we consider the options of the other actor
as well and expect that they do the same for
us.
And now, the first cool result is that if
we run the prisoner's dilemma with two of
these new LOLA agents, they quickly find the
Nash equilibrium.
This is great.
But wait, we have talked about this tit for
tat thing, so what's the big deal with that?
There is an iterated version of the prisoner's
dilemma game, where this snitching or cooperating
game is replayed many many times.
It is an ideal benchmark because an advanced
agent would know that we cooperated the last
time, so it is likely that we can partner
up this time around too!
And now comes the even cooler thing!
This is where the tit for tat strategy emerges
- these LOLA agents know that if the previous
time, they cooperated, they will immediately
give each other another chance, and again,
get away with the least amount of prison time.
As you can see here, the results vastly outperform
other naive agents, and from the scores it
seems that previous techniques enter a snitching
revenge war against each other and both will
serve plenty of time in prison.
Other games are also benchmarked against naive,
uncooperative agents, vastly outperforming
them.
This is a fantastic paper, make sure to check
it out in the video description for more details.
I found it to be very readable, so do not
despair if your math kung fu is not that strong.
Just dive into it!
Videos like this tend to get less views because
they have less visual fireworks than most
other works we're discussing in the series.
Fortunately, we are super lucky because we
have your support on Patreon and can tell
these important stories without worrying about
going viral.
And, if you have enjoyed this episode and
you feel that 8 of these videos a month is
worth a dollar, please consider supporting
us on Patreon.
One buck is almost nothing, but it keeps the
papers coming.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!